[Musik]
der innenminister in schwieriger mission
horst seehofer will in ankara und athen
den flüchtlings pakt mit der türkei
retten
mehr geld für den kampf gegen ebola
deutschland gibt noch mal weitere
millionen um die tödliche epidemie im
kongo einzudämmen
sensation in doha niclas kohl rot gold
und wird mit 21 jahren jüngster
zehnkampf weltmeister
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten heute mit viel
jubel aus doha beim sport und norbert
lehmann einen guten handorfer mir
gestern ankara heute athen es ist keine
einfache reise für innenminister
seehofer es geht darum den flüchtling
stil zwischen der eu und der türkei zu
retten der in letzter zeit immer weniger
zu funktionieren scheint seehofer hat
der türkischen regierung jetzt mehr geld
in aussicht gestellt
schauen wir uns den vertrag von 2016 an
wichtigste punkte migranten die illegal
nach griechenland kommen sollen in die
türkei zurückgeschickt werden können
die eu nimmt im gegenzug syrische
flüchtlinge aus der türkei auf doch
zuletzt waren wieder deutlich mehr
migranten von der türkei aus nach
griechenland und damit in die eu gelangt
er immer schön berichtet ein bisschen
wasser abgefüllt in alte plastikflaschen
die einzige leitung inmitten von
müllbergen maria na wai und der sohn
holen verpflegung in moria dem
flüchtlingslager auf der griechischen
insel lesbos die leute waschen hier ihr
geschirr sich selbst und trinken auch
noch davon und dann werden sie krank
anderes wasser gibt es hier nicht
ausgelegt auf 3000 lebenden marian
zwischen 12000 menschen die zustände
menschenunwürdig auf 100 flüchtlinge
kommt eine toilette für eine mahlzeit
steht man drei stunden in der schlange
vor mehreren wochen wurde ein
jugendlicher erstochen letzten sonntag
starben bei einem feuer eine frau und
ihr sohn eigentlich sollen in moria die
asylanträge überprüft und die
flüchtlinge dann weiter an die ebenen
verteilt oder zurückgeschickt werden
doch die griechischen behörden sind
heillos überfordert denn täglich land
neue boote aus der nur zwölf kilometer
entfernten türkei an
die türkische regierung soll gemäss
abkommen mit der eu genau das verhindern
doch fordert die türkei mehr geld von
der europäischen union
gestern reiste bundesinnenminister
seehofer nach ankara und sicherte
unterstützung zu heute mittag weiter
nach athen krisengespräch mit der
griechischen regierung eindringlich
warnte er vor einer neuen
flüchtlingskrise ich kann nur allen
mitgliedsländern in europa sagen wir
haben es ja schon erlebt wenn wir es
nicht gemeinsam angehen wird es zu einem
großen problem für jeden einzelnen
mitgliedstaat seehofers mission
vielleicht ein hoffnungsschimmer für die
menschen in moria thüringens
innenminister mayer warnt vor einem
erstarken rechtsextremer milieus die
entwicklung mache ihm große sorgen sagte
der spd politiker der welt überall in
mitteldeutschland wachse die szene
gerade im ländlichen raum
dort treten neonazis unverhohlen auf und
versuchten in bürgerliche milieus 1 zu
sichern
im sächsischen zwickau wurde ein gedenk
baum für das ns opfer enders im check
abgesägt regierungssprecher seibert
verurteilte die tat scharf schick war
der erste von insgesamt zehn menschen
die die terrorgruppe
nationalsozialistischer untergrund
umgebracht hat was darf ein us-präsident
und was darf er nicht die meinungen
gehen da immer mehr auseinander
da wäre einerseits donald trump selbst
nach der ukraine hat er jetzt auch noch
china aufgefordert gegen seinen rivalen
joe biden und dessen sohn zu ermitteln
unter während seine kritiker die das
nicht akzeptabel nennen und immer lauter
nach einem amtsenthebungsverfahren rufen
elmar theveßen donald schon im
angriffsmodus als präsident habe er das
recht korruptionsermittlungen gegen
jeden us bürger zu verlangen auch gegen
politische gegner ist joe biden
wahlkampf egal mir geht's um korruption
das sieht ausgerechnet der ehemalige
ukraine beauftragte der regierung kommt
volker an dass er lieferte den kongress
neue beweise dutzende von sms die folter
und andere diplomaten im sommer
ausgetauscht hatten einige waren
überzeugt dass trump die militärhilfe
für die ukraine vom vorgehen gegen
seinen politischen gegner
joe biden abhängig machte nein meint nur
ein anderer aber man solle darüber bitte
nicht mehr per sms kommunizieren
trump bestreitet dass er einen deal mit
seinem ukrainischen amtskollegen machen
wollte es gehe nur um
korruptionsbekämpfung auch china sollte
ermittlungen gegen beiden starten
gemeint sind geschäfte des sohnes von
joe biden in china auch wenn es auch
dort keine hinweise auf illegale
aktivitäten geht der präsident der
vereinigten staaten ermutigt erneut eine
fremde macht seinem wahlkampf mit
ermittlungen gegen einen politischen
gegner zu helfen das ist ein
fundamentaler bruch seines amtseides der
us-präsident sagt selbst er könne nach
der amerikanischen verfassung tun was er
wolle und deshalb dreht sich das
engagement verfahren immer mehr um die
frage wie die machtverhältnisse in den
vereinigten staaten von amerika
eigentlich verteilt sind wie in einer
demokratie oder wie in einem autoritären
system große sorge trieb heute auch den
generalinspekteur der geheimdienste vor
den kongress erhält die vorwürfe eines
whistleblowers für glaubwürdig dass
donald trump zu wahlkampfzwecken seine
macht missbraucht die regierung in
hongkong verschärft ihr vorgehen gegen
die demonstranten ein neues gesetz
verbietet den bürgern bei öffentlichen
versammlungen masken zu tragen
aus protest gingen tausende auf die
straße demonstranten nutzen masken um
nicht erkannt zu werden und sich vor
tränengas zu schützen
nach medienberichten wurde auch heute
ein junger aktivist angeschossen und
verletzt
proteste auch im irak es geht um jobs
bessere lebensverhältnisse und ein ende
der korruption und die staatsmacht kennt
kein pardon lässt in die menge schiessen
mehr als 60 tote bis jetzt die wut der
menschen richtet sich gegen die
regierung aber auch gegen den wachsenden
einfluss irans wie uli gack berichtet es
sind spontane demonstrationen zumeist
junger männer in bagdad gegen staatliche
korruption arbeitslosigkeit
misswirtschaft
anfangs friedlich bis sicherheitskräfte
am dienstag das feuer eröffnen
seither eskaliert die gewalt in fast
allen größeren städten des landes
dutzende menschen kommen ums leben weit
über 1000 werden verletzt
wir sind friedliche demonstranten wir
fordern nur unsere rechte warum feuern
sie auf uns sie haben junge männer
getötet
der irak im ausnahmezustand das land
versinkt in gewalt anscheinend iraks
premierminister abdul mahdi will
beruhigen erklärt die forderungen der
demonstranten für berechtigt
dennoch die wut auf der straße tobt
trotz einer ausgangssperre
mit versprechungen will uns der
premierminister für dumm verkaufen und
lässt mit scharfer munition auf uns
schießen
der protest richtet sich auch gegen die
einflussnahme des nachbarlandes iran
teheran habe irakische sicherheitskräfte
unterwandert sagen viele und schüre hier
gewalt diese reizgas kartusche kommt aus
dem iran sagen die demonstranten ein
geschenk sagen sie sarkastisch des
übermächtigen nachbarn
die proteste gehen weiter landesweit
gegen iran korruption und armut
gesundheitsminister sparen ist auf
afrika reise im gepäck weitere millionen
für den kampf gegen ebola
heute besucht er den kongo im norden des
landes war das ebola-virus 1976 entdeckt
und nach einem kleinen fluss benannt
worden
seit beginn der aktuellen epidemie
erkrankten knapp 3200 menschen mehr als
2100 davon starben
tim kröger berichtet
händewaschen und temperatur messen das
ist routine im ostkongo dennoch gelingt
es wegen der schwierigen sicherheitslage
in dem konfliktgebiet seit mehr als
einem jahr nicht den ebola ausbruch
unter kontrolle zu bringen
außerdem trauen noch immer viele
menschen den helfern nicht ich komme aus
der stadt des tempos dort gab es viel
widerstand gegen die helfer jetzt wird
es langsam besser und die menschen
glauben was die experten ihnen über die
krankheit erzählen
heute hat bundesgesundheitsminister jens
spahn den ostkongo besucht und weitere
finanzielle hilfe im kampf gegen ebola
in aussicht gestellt wir unterstützen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation mit
zusätzlichen 3 millionen euro um hier in
der krise auch mit den kräften vor ort
die auch finanziert werden müssen zu
helfen das ebola sich nicht weiter
verbreitet das ist nicht nur humanitäre
hilfe das ist aus eigenem interesse
aber es gibt auch hoffnung im ostkongo
durch eine wirksame impfung vor allem
aber durch neue medikamente erkranken
haben eine wirklich gute
überlebenschance von 90 prozent wenn sie
die medikamente rechtzeitig bekommen das
ist der schlüssel
es begann seiner tempo hat durch eben
jene medikamente überlebt für ihren mann
aber kam die hilfe zu spät
weil die menschen sollten wissen dass
ebola wirklich existiert sie sollten
aufhören das gegenteil zu sagen
derzeit sinken die fallzahlen ein ende
des ausbruchs sehen die experten vor ort
aber noch nicht
ja und nun zu der norbert und zum
sensationellen deutschen wm gold in ja
gestern abend um diese zeit deutete sich
an dass niklas kauf vielleicht bronze
holen könnte aber dank diese
spektakuläre aufholjagd des 21 mit der
hatte keiner gerechnet
der bislang jüngste könig der athleten
kommt aus deutschland
der junge könig von katar hatte sie
geahnt die gunst der stunde die chance
kriegst du vielleicht nie wieder in
meinem leben und die eine chance die du
jetzt kriegt die musst du dann halt eben
auch machen
nach schwachem ersten tag ist der nur
elfter dann persönliche bestleistungen
mit diskus und starb fünf meter andere
topleute patzen oder scheiden aus wie
der verletzte titelverteidiger aus
frankreich führt kommt der
schlüsselmoment mit dem speer 79 meter
und 5 so weiter auch keinen zehnkämpfer
im wettkampf geworfen auf einmal ist er
auf dem bronzeplatz
jetzt kann es um die medaille gehen und
das ist dann halt irgendwie knapp werden
kann zwischen damien michael und mir und
was danach passiert ist weiß ich nicht
mehr ganz so genau dem führenden ersten
mal könnte niveau nimmt der
entscheidende 16 sekunden ab und holt
sich vor ihm wm-gold mit 8600 91 punkten
dingen warner kanada wird dritter
paul ist der zweite deutsche zehnkampf
weltmeister nach ddr mann torsten voss
vor 32 jahren
von doha nach mainz niclas kohl ist
morgen am gast bei katrin müller
hohenstein im aktuellen sportstudio um
23 uhr 30 ja noch ein medaillenerfolg
gab es zu feiern dann christina
schwanitz vier jahre nach ihrem wm
triumph in peking kam die 33 hierhin
noch einmal aufs podest
die 19 17 im fünften versuch bescherten
mir das mal bronze gold ging wie 2017 an
die chinesin gong li jiao der
leverkusener offensivspieler nadim amiri
steht erstmals im kader der
nationalmannschaft für das testspiel
gegen argentinien kommenden mittwoch in
dortmund schlussmann wird marc andré ter
stegen sein
bundestrainer joachim löw gibt ihn also
im torhüter-duell mit manuel neuer die
versprochene bewährungschance kapitän
und neuer soll dann aber vier tage
später beim em qualifikationsspiel gegen
estland wieder dabei sein
gelungener auftakt für die deutschen
kunstturnerinnen bei den
weltmeisterschaften in stuttgart im
qualifikationswettkampf fliegt das
deutsche quintett im zwischenklassement
auf platz eins auch dank der starken
lokalmatadoren elisabeth seitz
sie darf auf die finalteilnahme am
stufenbarren und dem berg am schrocken
aber die ganz starken teams die treten
erst morgen an allen voran
titelverteidiger usa wird spannend
norbert das schier endlos anmutende
braig cit drama für viele das reinste
affentheater
wir treffen das bei sotheby's dieses
gemälde unter den hammer kam
schimpansen im britischen unterhaus
anstelle der abgeordneten
gemalt hat dass der britische street art
künstler banksy in london brachte das
kunstwerk die rekord summe von
umgerechnet knapp 11 millionen euro ein
über den neuen besitzer ist nichts
bekannt heute nacht und morgen regnet es
kräftig doch auch die sonne zeigt sich
wo das erfahren sie gleich von essent
elli so viel von uns für den moment
marietta slomka erwartet sie heute um 21
uhr 45
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
einen guten start ins wochenende und
sind morgen abend wieder für sie da
punkt 7 tschüss